what's the call of any clown no doubt
clowns have no doubt that's why they're
funny i mean
they they hit a challenge and they they
hit a wall
they get stopped but they don't they
don't
chaplin once he's stopped just
goes in another direction but he doesn't
back up and go oh god
you know they they
they get over they get over they don't
get
over it they get over it
keep going forward i remember tarantino
said some of the most brilliant thing
you know the director he said well hey
you know how do you just keep going he
says i think of myself as a pac-man you
know that game pac-man
he said i think of myself as a pac-man i
can't go back
i can only go forward in huge bites
and i thought cool